Raketen auf Kiew am 10 Oktober
entscheidet Putin auch die ukrainische
Hauptstadt wieder ins Visier zu nehmen
schießt mitten ins Zentrum er will dass
sie Angst haben sich nirgendwo sicher
fühlen
dabei hatte Kiew sich gerade vom
Kriegsbeginn als die Russen kurz vor der
Tür standen erholt noch am Wochenende
unmittelbar vor den Angriffen ist das
Leben zurück auf der Straße ein
Weinfestival und doch ist der Krieg
immer präsent die Winzer haben ihn
teilweise hautnah erlebt
unser Haus wurde von zwei Minen
getroffen und zerstört
wir waren zu dem Zeitpunkt auch zu Hause
in diesem Moment wurden aber nicht
verletzt
unser Haus war ziemlich kaputt aber wir
haben überlebt und werden weitermachen
ein bisschen Geld für sich und doch ist
das wichtigste hier die Wirtschaft am
Laufen halten damit der Krieg finanziert
werden kann
wir spenden die ganze Zeit an die Armee
wir machen alles was wir können für
unsere Jungs wir schauen was Sie
brauchen und wie wir helfen können wir
verdienen fast nichts weil wir wissen
dass dieses Geld keinen Sinn macht wenn
wir nicht gewinnen
auch die Erlöse dieser Party-Reihe gehen
zu großen Teilen an die Front 30.000
Euro hat Veranstalterin Thoma votuma
schon gespendet kurz vor dem Angriff
trauen sie sich noch zu tanzen es fühlte
sich so gut an
Monat bezahlt das ist leider ziemlich
beängstigend solche größeren Partys zu
veranstalten aber die Menschen hier
müssen sich irgendwie ablenken das ist
nicht einfach weil unser Feind uns
niederschmettern will aber das wird er
nicht schaffen
der Ahnen sie hier noch nicht dass nur
einen Tag später sich alle die ganze
Stadt zum ersten Mal seit Monaten wieder
in Bunkern verstecken muss nach diesem
Wochenende greift Putin Kiew an
[Applaus]
die Sonnenstrahlen scheinen durchs
Fenster dann tut es einen unfassbaren
Schlag neben seinem Bett so beginnt der
Morgen von Valerie pfaffowski in Kiew
ich war noch im Halbschlaf ich habe gar
nicht verstanden was los ist und dann
habe ich das Glas aus dem Fenster
fliegen sehen und die Balkontür sprang
auf ich habe Feuer gerochen und dann
Rauch gesehen
seine Frau wurde in diesem Haus geboren
es hat die Bomben des Zweiten Weltkriegs
überlebt und auch diesmal hat die
Familie Glück die Rakete verfehlt sie
ganz knapp Sohn Dimitri fährt sofort zu
den Eltern versucht die Scheiben
notdürftig zu reparieren sie wohnen
direkt am chefchenko-park mitten im
Zentrum
gibt es keine Militärbasis oder
militärische Ziele auch keine kritische
Infrastruktur in der Nähe das ist das
historische Stadtzentrum mit alten
Gebäuden uninteressant für den
russischen Feind sie wollten Zivilisten
treffen
wo eigentlich Kinder spielen ist nun ein
Krater
Putins Krieg ist zurück in der
Hauptstadt er will zeigen niemand ist
sicher zieht auf Menschen auf dem Weg
zur Uni Arbeit oder in die Schule doch
in Kiew trotzen sie sind kurz danach
wieder auf den Straßen
das hat mich alles an den 24 Februar
erinnert es hat mir Angst gemacht weil
es die letzten vier Wochen ruhig war in
Kiel
ich gehe nirgendwohin ich bleibe zu
Hause und bete für alle Menschen in der
Ukraine unsere Kämpfer für jeden und
jede
Bürgermeister Klitschko sagt im
ZDF-Interview russland habe mehr als 70
Raketen allein auf Kiew abgefeuert 40
konnten sie abfangen zu wenig um die
Sicherheit der Menschen zu garantieren
wir brauchen moderne Abwehrsysteme das
ist gegen Raketen hier besonders in
unserer Stadt so das macht die Leben von
unseren Anwohner ist viel sicherer
deswegen wir brauchen Hilfe sie wollen
sich nicht unterkriegen lassen Räumen
kurz nach den Angriffen schon auf nichts
hier soll an den Tod erinnern sie wollen
leben
doch dann einen Tag später müssen sich
die Menschen in der Ukraine wieder in
Sicherheit bringen russland hat erneut
mehrere Regionen beschossen wie
saporisha minica Kiew und Lemberg laut
Bürgermeister waren 30 Prozent der Stadt
ohne Strom dabei sind viele doch gerade
noch dabei die Schäden vom Kriegsbeginn
zu reparieren wie in irpin bevor Schnee
und Kälte kommen an Selina koordiniert
die Arbeiten an diesem Mehrfamilienhaus
wir werden es nicht schaffen in einem
Monat ganz fertig zu sein bevor es kalt
wird leider es ist viel Arbeit die
oberen Geschosse sind alle kaputt
wie sie hier bald wieder leben und nicht
frieren sollen
illusorisch im Nachbarort nowobi trifft
sie ist weniger kaputt die Sorge vor
einem kalten Winter ohne Strom trotzdem
da Sergi Kocak Salewski will vorsorgen
vor zwei Jahren hat er diese Terrasse
gebaut eigentlich um draußen mit
Freunden zu sitzen und zu grillen jetzt
mauert er sie zu um es im Winter wärmer
zu haben
um die 15 bis 20 Prozent an Heizkosten
sparen
das ist eine ziemlich günstige Lösung
die sich viele leisten könnten trotz
gestiegener Baukosten
ich werde wohl in einer Woche damit
fertig sein
er wohnt im Norden von Kiew die Russen
standen am Kriegsbeginn 10 km vor seiner
Haustür nun will er vorbereitet sein was
auch immer noch kommen mag
mit dem 24 Februar haben wir gelernt
immer einen Eimer Wasser oder zwei hier
zu haben und noch mehr er hat einen
Generator gekauft er funktioniert
er kann gleichzeitig den Kühlschrank den
Wasserkocher und das Licht am Laufen
halten Laptops und Smartphones laden
außerdem heize ich das Haus mit einem
Gasboiler
aber der läuft auch nicht ohne Strom
am Montag nach dem Angriff der Russen
auf Kiew kam der Generator gleich zum
Einsatz Stromausfall über mehrere
Stunden
alle Nachbarn zu mir um ihre Telefone
und Laptops zu laden und wir haben auf
einem Gaskocher zusammen gekocht richtig
leckere Kartoffeln
ganz ohne elektrisches Licht wir haben
mehrere Kerzen aufgestellt das hat uns
erinnert an unsere traditionellen Feste
wenn es dunkel ist und nur Kerzen an
das könnte Ihnen hier nun öfter
passieren nach den Angriffen auf die
kritische Infrastruktur will der
Stromnetzbetreiber von Kiew nun
vorbeugen um das Netz stabil zu halten
auf die Herbst Wintersaison
vorzubereiten hat unser Unternehmen
Zeitpläne erstellt für Notfälle und
kontrollierte Stromabschaltung über
mehrere Stunden
es könnte ein kalter und dunkler Winter
werden viele können nur hoffen einen so
gut vorbereiteten
in manchen Orten scheint es als hätte
sie das Glück seit Kriegsbeginn
verlassen
das war Lidia pilypenkus Haus in ihre
PIN ausgebrannt beim Angriff der Russen
im Frühling
wir haben dieses Haus mit unseren
eigenen Händen gebaut mein Mann und ich
Stein auf Stein
ihr Mann bekam kurz danach ein
Herzinfarkt hat diesen Schmerz nicht
überlebt doch Lidia ist nicht mehr
alleine der Garten an diesem Herbsttag
voller junger freiwilliger
schaut sie euch an sie sind wie Ameisen
so wirbelig und das macht meine Seele
froh
Ameisen die nicht nur den Schutt in
wenigen Stunden beseitigen sondern auch
Licht und Leben hierher zurückbringen
district one heißt ihre Organisation
jüngere helfen älteren sammeln Spenden
für Sie und bauen ihre Häuser wieder auf
so das kalte Wetter kommt bald und wir
haben gesehen dass sogar lidias Fahrrad
verbrannt ist
dank einem anonymen Spender konnten wir
ihr ein neues kaufen
und dann haben wir Geld gesammelt und
sind mit einem Team freiwilliger
hierhergekommen
[Musik]
und Helferin Sophia sie waren Fremde und
sind sich jetzt ganz nah
sdorf natürlich schaffst du das du bist
ein starker Soldat auch wenn du eine
kleine Frau bist aber stark in dir drin
alles wird wieder gut
ich weine nicht wegen diesem Desaster
ich weine wegen unserer kraftvollen
schönen Jugend
die Freiwilligen kommen aus allen Teilen
des Landes sind teilweise selbst
geflohen und helfen nun anderen sowie
Serie ich bin aus rerson hierher
gekommen ich wusste nicht wohin habe
erst in Odessa für eine Weile gelebt und
kam dann nach Kiew und habe bei district
one angefangen jetzt helfe ich jeden Tag
zum Schluss sagt Lidia noch
mit unserer Jugend muss man sich vor
nichts fürchten nicht vor Krieg oder
irgendeiner Katastrophe von nichts sie
werden alles aufräumen wieder aufbauen
und alles wird wieder schön werden
daran glaubt sie ganz fest
[Musik]